[Music]
well I had the pleasure of chatting with
the man behind Beyonce's iconic single
ladies dance bees leave choreographer
Jack well night and after seeing the
sleigh he brought to any Rd and
Rihanna's Lemon video it all makes sense
why Forbes just named him one of their
30 young artists and visionaries under
30 and of course I also had to learn the
latest dance craze from the master
himself okay so now we got to talk about
the present time you're working with any
of any Rd on you choreographed the lemon
video which was so so dope I mean what's
it like working for those guys oh my god
you know Pharrell is just the craziest
artist you know like talk about someone
who's ahead of his time you know and
just someone who gets it you know so
it's been all some time in the studio
with him you know heating such great
energy and his love is so real for the
heart you know and he's so proud of
women you know he's so he's like what
he's like what would lemon beat without
the choreography you know it's such a
great project to be a part of you know
what inspired the choreography free
lemons
spent a lot of time studying like Soul
Train performances from the seventies
and you know like Tina Turner
performances like what was that energy
back then that those that they had that
was so captivating you know and
mesmerizing look away you know so I
wanted that I wanted lemons to feel like
that you know and would celebrate dance
well you it's lightning in a bottle man
you have a knack for uh for creating
these dance so that ever wants to do it
in fact this person wants to learn it
you ready teach me lemon are you ready
to get know already I've been watching
the video all morning I go yeah so I
brought my good friend here jasmine you
know she's one of my assistant
choreographers on the project you know
and she has the Bob she this is the the
answers up the vibe you know okay yeah
there's different dances and each one
has that all identity so what are we
learning today
the lemon the actual lemonade naturally
gonna show you the Obama the Obama here
that the Obama okay okay
it's a barack or michelle both okay we
ready all right hands like this and
we're gonna push to the right
you're gonna whip your head to the right
hey am i doing it so the barman gonna
hit you're gonna do a cross and well and
then you kind of kind of levitate on
your legs I mean on your feet you want
to kind of levitating you're like oh you
got it light as a feather no
presidential okay should we try one
music music here we go ba okay Sammy
here we cut here we go hey hey
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
you